the base unit for distance in the metric
system is
the meter and to get a sense of how long
a meter is the average human being is
between 1.5 and 2 meters tall so 1.5
meters would be a a not so tall person
but two meters would be quite tall in
fact if you're two meters tall or above
two meters tall you might want to
consider basketball so for example in
this drawing right over here by leonardo
da vinci a meter if this is an average
sized male a meter might be about a
meter might be about it would be more
than halfway across his wingspan so it
might be about that much and obviously i
am just roughly drawing this just to
give you a sense of how far a meter
might be and i just wrote a lowercase m
here as really just a short way of
writing meter so you can imagine that
the at the the smaller things that you
might want to measure with the with the
meter are things like a human being a
human being's height or a human being's
wingspan if you wanted to say well what
are some of the larger things that you
would want to measure with a meter you
might imagine something like the height
of a skyscraper so this right over here
is the empire state building once at one
time the tallest building in the world
now just atol building in the world and
this is 443
meters tall
443 meters tall
so this is starting to be kind of on the
larger scale of things that you would
want to measure with a meter now you're
probably asking well what happens if i
want to measure things that are even
larger than that
well the metric system provides us
prefixes to essentially say multiples of
meters and the one that's typically the
the the unit of distance that is larger
than the meter that is most typically
used is the kilometer
so the kilometer i've heard a few people
say kilometer but kilometer
i'll pronounce it kilometer which is
equivalent to 1 000
meters
and so when you're thinking about
kilometers this is thinking about the
distance within a city this would be
even the distance from one city to
another city even the the radius of the
planet is often measured in kilometers
often measured in kilometers and to once
again get a sense of that if you get a
sense of that this right over here is a
map of new york city and right over here
they give us the scale this distance
right over here is five
is five kilometers so five kilometers
just to give us a sense of things and
they wrote km for short so 5 km
5 km this lowercase k lowercase m is the
shorthand for kilometers this would be
equal to well if one kilometer is 1000
meters five kilometers is going to be
five times as many it's going to be five
thousand
five
thousand meters is this distance right
over here if you were to try to imagine
one kilometer it'd be one-fifth of that
so one kilometer on this map
might look something
might look something like that
now there's other units in the metric
system that allow us to describe
distances
less than a kilometer but more than a
meter but they're not as typically used
but i'll list them here just to see just
so that you see that they exist you have
the hectometer or hectometer
it's so infrequently used that i really
haven't heard a lot of people say it
which is equal to 100 meters
and you have the
decameter or decameter and i actually
think it's decameter
deca-meter
decameter which is 10 meters and i'm
going to write these in orange because
they're not that frequently used for
example no one would ever say or it's
not typical to hear someone say that the
empire state building is 4.43
hectometers or for them to say that this
is 44.3
deca meters they would typically say
that this is 443
meters
now you're probably saying okay well
this is fine i'm able to
using these prefixes on the meter i'm
able to describe distances that are
larger than a meter that are multiples
of
of tens of of the meter or multiple 100
or multiple of a thousand of the meter
but what if i want to go smaller well
the metric system has units for that
and if we go just one tenth of a meter
this is not used as typically but i'll
write it here the decimeter
the decimeter is one tenth
of a meter or another way of saying it
is one meter
is equal to 10
decimeters lowercase dm for short once
again this is not so typically used but
if we go one scale even below that we
get to the centimeter which is a heavily
used unit
we get to the centimeter
centimeter and here the prefix centi
means one hundredth so this is one
hundredth of a meter 100 of a meter
another way of thinking about it one
meter is equal to 100 centimeters and if
you wanted to imagine the scale of a
centimeter you could imagine this frog
right over here on this person's hand
might be several centimeters long so a
centimeter on this drawing might be
around that distance now if you want to
measure things even smaller than that we
have another fairly common unit and that
is the millimeter
that is
the millimeter and the prefix milli here
refers to one thousandth so it's one
thousandth
of
a meter or another way of thinking about
it is one meter
one meter is equal to one thousand
one thousand millimeter actually right
let me just write m for short just so we
get used to also seeing it that way one
meter is equal to one thousand
one thousand
millimeters
and if you wanted to imagine how long or
how far a millimeter is you could go
down the scale of things that are
smaller than a centimeter so these ants
for example might be three or four
millimeters long so a millimeter in this
drawing right over here might be
might be something like that
the important thing to realize is or
just to conceptualize as well you know
you might want to use different units
depending on the scale that you're
measuring and it's also useful to just
realize what these typical prefixes
refer to because we're seeing it used in
distance here they're all based on the
base unit of distance but in other when
we're measuring volume or we're
measuring other things in the metric
system these same unit these same
prefixes also show up so you see here
when we're measuring distance kilo
refers to a thousand a kilometer is
literally one thousand meters hecto
refers to a hundred a hectometer hundred
meters deca refers to tan deci refers to
one tenth so decimeter literally one
tenth of a meter centimeter one
hundredth one hundredth of a meter
milli refers to one thousandth